after a chance encounter with a young
David Letterman Chris Elliot went from
being a mild-mannered NBC gofer to a
writer and performer and Letterman's
groundbreaking talk-show from 1982 to
1989 Elliott honed his craft helping the
program to earn multiple Emmys for
outstanding writing in a variety series
those early years helped to pave the way
for the quirky actor best known for his
scene-stealing roles in films such as
Groundhog Day there's something about
Mary and scary-movie Hansen caretaker
but since the early 2000s alia has kept
a fairly low profile he is what he's
been up to weird from the start
first a bit of backstory Chris Elias
father Bob Elia was a popular comedian
and radio personality in the 1950s most
notable for his legendary work with
comedy partner ray Golding David
Letterman's love for Bob's work helped
Chris get his career changing
opportunity a late night in 1990 Elliott
teamed up with two guys who used to work
on Late Night with him to bring the
short-lived sitcom get a life to Fox
featuring writers like mr. shows Bob
Odenkirk and adaptations Charlie Kaufman
it's safe to say the program was
different from anything on TV it was all
too weird for Fox and the network pulled
the plug after just two seasons but it's
considered a cult classic today
two years later Elliott co-wrote and
starred in another genuinely strange
piece of entertainment the Tim Burton
produced flop cabin boy which also
enjoys cult status today Elliott's
TARDIS snobby aristocrat turned sea
captain and the Fanueil Mayweather in
which is certainly the weirdest movie of
his career which also featured a cameo
from his old pal David Letterman I
realize that
you are most likely the product of
lower-class inbreeding but perhaps you
could help me oh gosh I certainly hope
so
steady gesta his first film as a leading
man was a critical and financial
disaster but Elliott soon found his
footing after a string of small roles
and high-profile flicks in the late 90s
and early 2000s Elliott has continued
working steadily primarily in supporting
and guest starring stints on a number of
popular TV sitcoms and dramas alongside
small roles and more than a dozen shows
like
Lauren order SVU difficult people and
the Good Wife he appeared in ten
episodes of Everybody Loves Raymond as
Amy's comic book loving older brother
pizza
he also played Lily's father Mickey in
multiple seasons of How I Met Your
Mother in October 2017 Elliott made his
guest starring debut on Fox's Apocalypse
themed comedy the last man on earth
playing a castaway named Glenn failed
family sitcom in 2006 Elliott to the
plans to bring his family to television
with the sitcom you've reached the
Elliott's
the CBS series was going to follow
Elliott a husband and a father of two
struggling with the balance of raising a
family in Connecticut as he pursued a
b-list acting career in Hollywood split
cider described the concept as getalife
cross with Everybody Loves Raymond
except the series would have taken a
meta looker Eliot's real life through a
cringe inducing comedic lens while this
sounds like a winning formula with meta
comedy hits like Curb Your Enthusiasm
changing the small screen landscape the
project was ultimately passed on by the
network late-night reunion Elliott
returns sporadically to Late Night with
David Letterman
during the 2007 2008 season more than
two decades a synthesis emmy-winning
work on the CBS staple he appeared in
multiple sketches throughout the year as
recurring characters including skink a
bounty hunter of some unorthodox methods
we basically tease the guy til he's down
there in that hot box you know wearing
the old flop suit Wow
back to his roots when Adult Swim's
Eagle hearts came calling in 2011 things
came full circle for Elliott with the
starring role on a TV show suited for
his oddball sensibilities Eagle Hearts
creator Jason Warner was a big fan of
Elliott's work and get to life and
cupboard boy and while the show wasn't
written with him in mind
it was reworked to suit his comedic
stylings in 2015 Elliott joined the cast
of a Canadian sitcom with a ridiculous
name we can't say here the Christopher
Guest style comedy reunites Catherine O
Hara with Eugene Levy as formerly
wealthy magnates forced to move to a
small town the hilarity is capped off by
Chris Elias performance as Roland the
white-trash mullet wearing beer-guzzling
mayor of the Rosa's new home since
hitting Netflix it's found a new
audience and was renewed for a fourth
season in March 2017 comedy legacy
earlier past the comedy torch to his two
daughters Abby and bride a bride E has
worked a lot in the world of stand-up
comedy and has also acted in the TBS
series search partay
HBO's Silicon Valley and the Emma Stone
Steve Carell movie battle of the sexes
like a father before her
Abby appeared as a cast member on
Saturday Night Live from 2008 to 2012
making her the first-ever second
generation performer on the long-running
sketch series thanks for watching click
the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all the
school stuff we know your love to
[Music]